The Joe Rogan Experience and my brain
I'm thinking okay well I I only thought
the only option was to be a music
teacher
in my head I'm going well that's the
only option is to be a music teacher and
I don't want to be a music teacher
because I'm really bad
like I can't read music I I like I'm
like I can't do math like I have some
sort of like
I just can't so you can't read music wow
not at all and like
like it's I've probably some sort of
form of like dyslexia probably to the
truest extent like barely past math have
you tried to read music yeah oh yeah I
mean what happened I was in um so her so
her husband was actually the band
teacher he taught advanced placement
music theory which was a new class my
senior year I took that class
and got like a d
because it was like all these the kids
that were the best at band and the best
at chorus where he was in that class
only like eight students in the class
and all it is was Advanced like here's
the notes here's this I tried out for
Allstate chorus three years in high
school and didn't make it because you
had to be able to read you had to do a
sight singing audition which is where
they would hand you a piece of sheet
music
and you had to sing it just by reading
the notes on there right so as a
combination of what your voice sounded
like and your ability to keep up with
the All-State choir teacher whoever that
was picked out to be and I never made it
because I couldn't read the music
I just couldn't do it I I don't know why
you get coaching on it did you get like
yeah I mean I try I mean I busted to try
to it's just something about it doesn't
doesn't make sense to me like to my
brain like I get it like if I sit there
and like plank it out really really slow
I mean I could figure it out right but
it just doesn't it's just such to me
it's such an instinctual thing you know
and so I was in an acapella group my
freshman year at college for a year
um I enjoyed that but again it was just
like an after-school kind of activity
thing with other people in college you
know excuse to have people to drink with
really you know people with common
ground or whatever
and gave that up my beginning of my
sophomore year really
um and then didn't do music I played
rugby I got into playing rugby in
college I did that loved that and I was
just the guy that would like sing at
parties or whatever like my buddies that
played rugby with knew I sang
hey black dude's saying for these chicks
or whatever you know it was kind of like
I was like party trick guy you know and
then after my junior year I moved home
to Asheville and I we I'd always moved
home every summer up to that point and
then my mom goes because I was sulking
because all my buddies that year they
all stayed in their college town for the
summer I was the only guy that moved
back so all my friends are gone they're
in Raleigh they're in Charlotte they're
in Chapel Hill they're in Boone they're
in you know Kali and all these different
schools
so I'm working at the same job I have
when I was 16 at a go-kart place with a
bunch of high school kids I'm 21 years
old
I got nobody to hang out with I'm living
in my parents house I'm not doing well
in school I don't know what I want to do
with my life at all and I'm sitting on
the porch I remember sitting on my
parents carport and it was like my mom
come out and she was like what's wrong
with you like what's
what's I'm an only child too so
she's like what's what's going on and I
was like I don't know miles you don't
have any friends here like I'm working
at [__] go-karts you know like what
am I doing
and she's like well you know you know
what Luke Kenny Chesney and Tim McGraw
they didn't even learn to play guitar
till they were 21 years old
and I was 21 right and so my parents had
bought me a guitar in seventh grade that
I never played I did two guitar lessons
and hated it because my parents wanted
me to do it you know what I mean like
anything your parents want you to do you
don't want to do really
and so I went in the closet and I got
this oh it's like an Ibanez like 50
acoustic guitar you know just horrendous
condition but I didn't know that didn't
know anything about guitar
didn't know what a good guitar was
didn't know nice guitars even existed so
I taught myself all summer I just sat on
the porch when I wasn't at work
playing playing playing because I knew I
love to sing
and I was like well I'll just learn how
to play and I can sing at like parties
for my buddies or whatever and
taught myself all year and then just
kind of became obsessed with like
learning how to play and by the time I
was 22 I'm back in school I'm in Boone
hanging out my buddies I'm
starting to dabble around with like
writing my own songs because I was like
well I could you know this would be cool
I like this and then I wrote my first
two or three songs and I booked a gig
down the street just like at this bar my
rugby team always hung out at because I
figured that guy would you know he was
like the cokehead like wild card like
he'd give me a show or whatever you know
the guy was awesome you know I was like
this guy give me a show if I want to do
a show so I borrowed my neighbor's
guitar because mine wasn't even acoustic
electric it was just a straight up
acoustic and
sat on a stool my other buddy let me
borrow his PA speakers
and 200 of my friends came out and paid
a dollar to see me I made 200 bucks that
night that was more than I made it both
my jobs that week
and I was hooked man I was like dude
this is awesome like I love doing this
first off
yeah I'm like I love doing this anyways
and I'm having a great time I'm like
having drinks with my friends
everybody's psyched to see me here and
stuff
and I was like it just made sense man it
wasn't it wasn't one ounce of hard work
in my mind after that point
it was just always fun man and I always
loved it wow so it's like a door opened
up you walked through it yep and your
life changed forever it just made sense
dude yeah it was like a true like
aha moment right like you hear about
those from people oh I think I might
flip the top yeah
and you hear about those things but it
truly was that it was truly an aha
moment man and it was life it was a
life-changing man I don't know what I'd
be doing if I hadn't done that that's so
awesome I love those kind of stories
I really do